Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Tokös. Ich bin zuständig erzelt für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, hauptsache mir hilft jemand.
Ja. Okay, wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Frank Betke.
Ja, Herr Frank, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen stabieren?
Ja, Frank ist der Vorname S-R-A-N-K.
Ja, und Nachname?
Der Nachname Betke, B-E-T-H-G-E.
Betke.
Mhm, genau.
Okay, freut mich Herr Betke. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre.
Noch.
Okay, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m und wieg 114 kg.
114.
Ja, okay. Herr Betke, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für welche Welt haben Sie?
Ja, wissen Sie, seit heute Morgen habe ich solche heftigen Schmerzen in meinem Fuß.
Das sticht ganz stark in dem rechten Fuß vorne an der großen Zähne.
Und ich konnte überhaupt nicht mehr auftreten.
Ich habe mir jetzt hier vorne an der Krankenhausforte ein Rollstuhl geben lassen,
weil ich überhaupt nicht mehr auftreten kann mit dem Fuß.
Und meine Frau hat mich mit dem Auto hierher gebracht.
Also ich kann überhaupt nicht auftreten auf dem Fuß und es tut so weh.
Mhm.
Okay, haben Sie wegen diesen Schmerzen etwas angenommen, eine Schmerzmitte angenommen?
Ja, ich habe eine Aspirin genommen, aber es hat eigentlich gar nichts gebracht.
Okay, wie viel Milligramm 500 oder?
Ja, da habe ich zwei nacheinander genommen.
Zwei? 500?
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Betke, wie stark diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10, wobei nun kein Schmerzen 10, 6 Teil Schmerzen nennen.
Oh, das sind schon richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Also, ich sage mal so, bei 7 bis 8 sind die Schmerzen, die sind richtig...
Also ich kann überhaupt nicht auftreten, das tut richtig weh.
Okay, verstehe.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen aufhalten bis unsere Gespräche...
Ja, das wird ja nicht ewig dauern, ja.
Okay.
Herr Betke, streichen diese Schmerzen irgendwo aus oder nur ihren rechtsseitigen Großzehnen-Schmerzen?
Ja, also da praktisch am Anfang der Großzehne, da am Fuß, da tut es so weh.
Da tut es richtig dool, wie es sticht und klopft.
Es ist ganz übel.
Nee, es strahlt nicht aus.
Stimmt die kultiven Schmerzen.
Okay.
Gab es etwas, was diese Schmerzen liegen da oder verstärkt?
Ja, also wenn ich versuche, rumzulaufen, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Also es geht ein bisschen besser, wenn ich den Fuß hochlege, dann kann ich es aushalten, ja.
Aber sobald ich da draufstehe oder wenn ich versuche zu laufen, geht gar nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon diese Großzehnen, Rötungen, Überwärmung bemerkt?
Ich habe, als ich mir den Socken ausgezogen habe, habe ich das gesehen, dass das ganz heiß und rot ist, ja.
Das ist auch ein bisschen angeschwollen.
Okay.
Rötung.
Was haben Sie gestern gegessen oder getrunken?
Zu viel Alkohol oder Fleisch gegessen?
Fleisch esse ich ja immer und Alkohol trinke ich auch, aber nicht so viel.
Ich trinke regelmäßig ein paar Flaschen Bier am Abend, aber also nicht viel.
Und das trinke ich ja immer.
Ja. Wie viel Alkohol jeden Tag haben Sie getrunken?
Ja normal, das trinke ich so 2-3 Flaschen Bier am Abend.
2-3 Flaschen.
Seit wann?
Ja, schon ewig, also seit ich ja wachsen bin.
Okay.
Und Flaschen haben Sie auch versucht, Gemüse, Obst gegessen oder nur jeden Tag Flaschen essen?
Fleisch.
Ich esse natürlich viel Fleisch, ja, also eigentlich esse ich jeden Tag Fleisch, ja.
Entweder Wurst oder Fleisch oder ja, so selten mal was anderes.
Okay. Habt ihr sie, haben Sie, Sie sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, mein Gewicht ist immer gleich, also ich wiege mich natürlich jetzt nicht jeden Tag,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich zugenommen habe oder abgenommen habe.
Okay. Habt ihr viel Bauch?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, also heiß fühlt sich an, nicht nur der Fuß da unten an.
Aber keine Fieber, fühlen Sie sich nicht, der...
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, nee.
Nach Schweit oder Schutterfrost?
Nein, nach Nacht habe ich nicht geschwitzt, nee, nee, nee.
Und Schüttelfrost habe ich auch nicht, nee, nee.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Traume oder Verletzungen gehabt?
Ich habe mir den Finger nicht getragen, aber am Frühstück habe ich mir nichts getan, nein.
Okay. Und Sie sind in letzter Zeit ins Ausland gewesen, ich meine lange Reise.
Eine lange Reise habe ich nicht gemacht, nee, nee, ich war auch überhaupt nicht im Ausland,
nein, wir waren eigentlich nur zu Hause.
Okay. Verstehe, wie ist Ihre Appetit? Ich denke gut.
Der ist immer sehr, sehr gut, ja, der ist ein bisschen zu gut, ja,
Sie sehen ja, ne, ein bisschen übergewichtig, ja.
Okay. Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserless und Stuhlgang?
Nee, das eigentlich funktioniert, das ist immer gut.
Okay. Stuhlgang auch gut.
Ja, leiden Sie auch an Herzproblemen,
Rasen, Herzstorben oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, nein, nein, also nein, das kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Verstehe, ist Ihnen übel, ist Ihnen schwindelig, haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, nein, nein, mein Fuß tut mir weh.
Nur Fuß, verstehe.
Haben Sie früher einiges wie ich werden?
Nein, ich kenne das gar nicht, deswegen bin ich ja gleich gekommen,
weil es so sehr weh tut, ja.
Ja, ist das nur einmal, was ich hier...
Das ist jetzt das erste Mal, dass ich so etwas erlebe, ja.
Verstehe. Okay.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen,
ich meine Bluthochdruck,
erhöhte Blutfettwerte oder alte...
Ja, das hat mein Arzt mal gesagt, ich müsste ein bisschen mit dem Fett aufpassen,
weil ich ein bisschen hohe Werte habe, aber ich nehme da keine Medikamente.
Okay, seid wann?
Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, aber vielleicht so fünf, sechs Jahre,
da hat er das mal gesagt.
Und leiden Sie an Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, nein, nein.
Bluthochdruck?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber ich glaube nicht, ich wüsste es nicht.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Hausarzt?
Naja, nicht so wirklich regelmäßig,
nur wenn es unbedingt sein muss, wenn gar nichts mehr geht.
Okay. Sie leiden nur erhöhte Bluthochwerte, sonst noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen Magenprobleme,
dann habe ich so Sudbrennen, ja, wenn ich ein bisschen viel getrunken habe
oder wenn ich zu scharf gegessen habe, oder manchmal habe ich Sudbrennen
und dann nehme ich dann so Tabletten dagegen.
Seit wann leiden Sie an diese Sudbrennen?
Ach, das habe ich ja nicht immer, das habe ich nur hin und wieder mal,
wenn ich extrem fettig gegessen habe oder eben scharf gegessen
oder bei bestimmten Speisen so, ne?
Okay, oder viel Alkohol?
Oder dann ja.
Wegen dieser Probleme, für Sie eine Gastromagelspiegelung geführt?
Nee, so was haben wir noch nie gemacht.
Okay. Leiden Sie an nur Sudbrennen auch aufstoßen,
leiden Sie an auch aufstoßen, völlig gefühlt?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, also manchmal eben so ein Brunnen,
aber sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay, was nehmen Sie dagegen, Sie haben schon gesagt?
Ja, das sind so Tabletten, die heißen Omelprazol.
Omelprazol.
Nehmen Sie Baybedarf?
Nehmen Sie Baybedarf dann, ja.
Nehmen Sie Dosierung, wie sind Sie?
Sonst ist das 40 Milligramm?
Ich meine, das sind 40 Milligramm, ja.
40 Milligramm, Baybedarf, ein, ein.
Okay.
Dosung, noch etwas.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder Baybedarf?
Nee, also wie gesagt, wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
mal so Kopfschmerzen oder jetzt eben für den Fuß,
da habe ich mal Aspirin genommen.
Das habe ich halt immer am Strand.
Baybedarf, Aspirin.
Okay, 500 Milligramm.
Okay, färschte, Sie sind allergisch gegen etwas.
Dann müsste ich überlegen, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich
irgendwas allergisch bin.
Nee, ich kann alles essen, alles trinken
und habe auch nicht so etwas wie Heuchenupfen oder so.
Nee, ich glaube, ich bin überhaupt nicht allergisch.
Und keine Unfertiglichkeiten?
Was meinen Sie mit Unfertigungen?
Ich kann alles vertragen.
Alle Obst und Gemüse, Sie können vertragen.
Ja, Obst und Gemüse esse ich ja nicht so viel,
aber wenn ich etwas esse, das kann ich gut vertragen.
Okay, und haben Sie auch keine Medikamentallergie?
Ja, ich habe bisher in meinem Leben nicht so viel Medikamente genommen.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auch irgendwas allergisch bin.
Okay, wurde Sie schon einmal appelliert?
Ja, hinter habe ich natürlich irgendwann meine Blinddarm-Operation gehabt, ja.
Okay, und sonst noch etwas?
Nee, sonst bin ich noch ganz komplett.
Okay, Blinddarm-Operation.
Wie alt sind Sie, wie alt ist diese Operation?
Ja, das war so mit 14 oder so.
Okay.
Sie haben keine Traum- und Verletzungen
und haben Sie in Krankenhaus gewesen?
Wie damals mit dem Blinddarm natürlich, ja.
Sonst noch keine Traum- und Verletzungen?
Sonst vielleicht auch nie im Krankenhaus, ne?
Rachen Sie?
Nee, rachen Sie nicht.
Niemals, Sie rachen Sie niemals.
Nein, ich trink gerne Bier, aber geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Okay, verstehe.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich, es ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nee, natürlich nicht, nein.
Okay, verbeckte, verbeckte.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Nee, also bei meinem Vater ist bekannt, dass der Magenkrebs hat
und der ist da in Behandlung, aber meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Okay.
Wie behandelt er die Operation?
Der ist operiert worden, ja.
Oh, schön.
Der ist so ein Stück, glaube ich, vom Magen rausgeschnitten worden.
Aber eigentlich hat er sich ganz gut erholt jetzt davon.
Ja, super. Wie alt ist der?
Na, der ist Anfang 70.
70?
Anfang 72.
Ja, 17, okay.
Und Ihre Mutter ist gesund.
Meine Mutter ist gesund, ja, also, das will ich weiß.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja.
Ist er gesund?
Ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite als Schlosser in einer Maschinenfabrik.
Schlosser?
Welche Aufgaben haben Sie? Welche Tätigkeit?
Ja, also, die Maschinen zusammenzusetzen und praktisch das funktionieren,
der Maschinen sicherzustellen und überwachen und ja.
Schlosser, ja, okay.
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit oder im Leben?
Nein, eigentlich nicht besonders, kann ich nicht sagen.
Der Firma läuft und ja, manchmal wird es ein bisschen laut,
aber eigentlich macht mir die Arbeit Spaß.
Haben Sie keine Gehörprobleme oder?
Was habe ich?
Das ist richtig laut, können wir ja Urschutz aufsetzen,
aber normalerweise habe ich, wie gesagt, bei der Arbeit keine Probleme.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrem Frau zusammen?
Ja, ja, mit der Frau und den Kindern, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Drei.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind alles fit, ja.
Gut, sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona habe ich drei Impfungen gehabt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man da jetzt wieder etwas haben muss,
aber sonst, ja, früher als Kind hat man natürlich so alle Impfungen bekommen,
aber jetzt in letzter Zeit bin ich lange nicht geimpft worden.
Okay, verstehe, aber haben Sie gerade keine offene Wunder, oder?
Ne offene Wunder wüsste ich nicht, nee.
Okay, gut.
Sie treiben sich sportregelmäßig?
Siehst du so aus?
Nee, also Sport ist wirklich nicht meins, nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Betke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für Sie.
Ich möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder?
Ja, ich will natürlich nicht wissen, was das mit dem Fuster auf sich hat,
warum der das so weh tut und was man dagegen machen kann.
Ja, Herr Betke, ich habe für Sie Verdacht.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine gute, wegen Ihren Alkohol Trinkgewohnheiten
und 7-Tag-Fleischessen leider diese Krankheit verursachen.
Ich meine, ich bin krank, weil Fleisch ist doch gesund
und das bisschen Alkohol, 3-Fleisch und Bier ist doch noch nicht gesund.
Natürlich, Fleisch ist gesund, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Aber irgendwas muss man ja essen, ne?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine, wegen dieser,
ja, viel Fleisch und Alkohol konsumieren, eine Krankheit.
Das ist noch krank?
Ja, das ist eine Giftkrankheit.
Sie sollten deswegen, ich brauche Untersuchungen,
Blutuntersuchungen und eine Röntgen gegeben,
das ist ultrischal, aber Sie nachdem untersuchen,
aber ich gebe sofort für Sie eine Schmerz, Tabletten,
das ist gut, ja.
Ja, Ibuprofen, 600-800 Milligramm für Sie geben
und danach werde ich etwas empfehlen.
Bitte denken Sie daran, dass Sie entweder totale Alkohol aufzuhören
oder reduzieren, Sie sollten Ihren Alkoholgewünheiten wiederdenken.
Ja, aber ein bisschen, was brauchen wir denn ja schon zum trinken abends, ne?
Ja, natürlich, einmal in der Woche vielleicht, aber jeden Tag Alkohol...
Nein, das mache ich jetzt schon mal eben lange,
weil ich ja nicht dran sterben werde.
Verstehe. Aber wir sind, gibt es hier eine Sozialberatel,
wenn Sie Alkohol mit dem Alkohol aufzuhören, können wir gerne bei Ihnen helfen.
Ich will aber gar nicht mit dem Alkohol auf, wenn das gehört zu meinem Leben dazu.
Aber ich bin gefährlich.
Ja, dann müssen wir noch mal drüber reden, jetzt gucken wir erstmal, was tatsächlich ist.
Okay, vielleicht.
Natürlich.
Okay, möchte jemand noch etwas wissen von Herrn Betke?
Keine Frage, das ist ja gut.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, doch.
Ich strahle um die Schmerzen aus, ich habe nicht gehört.
Hat sie am Anfang gefragt, bleibt ganz am Anfang, hat sie gefällt, die Strahlen nicht aufleihen.
Okay, danke.
Brauchen Sie ein bisschen Zeit?
Also erst mal noch, sind noch mehr Fragen?
Ja, darf ich.
Hätten Sie ein bisschen Beschwerden für...?
Nee, das ist das erste Mal, das hat sie aber auch gefragt.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn es weiter geht...
Hallo, schönen guten Abend Frau Obererzen.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wer haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, es geht um Herr Frank Betke.
Er ist 46 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß und 114 kg schwer.
Ja, er ist Adipositas.
Er hat Adipositas.
Herr Betke, ich habe dich bei uns wegen, seit heute Morgen, plötzlich aufgetretene,
recht, plötzlich aufgetretene, stechende, klopfende, rechtseitige, grossenen Gelenk,
grossen Gelenk Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7-8 von 10 auf der LS.
Dagegen nehme er als 500 mg zweimal angenommen.
Hab er angenommen, ne?
Ja, dagegen habe er als 500 mg zweimal angenommen.
Aber das, das nicht geholfen habe.
Was haben Sie nicht geholfen?
Die Schmerzen würden keine strahlen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus?
Ja, die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Außerdem seien bei ihm die folgenden Begleitzentome aufgefallen.
Bewegungsanschränkungen, Überwärmung, Rötung
und Ödem.
Wo?
Ja, im grossen, fussgroßen, rechtseitige grossen, Fussgelenk.
Grundgelenk, grossen Grundgelenk.
Ja, ich habe die Schmerzen immer zu viel Alkohol,
täglich, bis zu 3 Flächen Bier, und jeden Tag Flaschen gegessen.
Die Fragen nach Fibatrauma, Verletzung,
Schmerzen, Herzproblemen wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnesie ist unauffällig,
bis auf Zotbrennen oder Reflexkrankheiten.
Die Vorerkrankungen seien die folgenden Bekannt.
An Vorerkrankungen seien die folgenden Bekannt.
Die Epidemie seit 4 bis 6 Jahren, dagegen nehmen keine Medikamente.
Und Reflexkrankheiten ab und zu extrem fetige Essen oder viel Alkohol getrunken.
Nach fetigem Essen oder erheblichem Alkoholkonsum?
Ja, die Medikamente anamnesi ergab,
einnahmete von Omeprazol, 4,6 mg, Byebedarf, Einmite,
und aspirin 500 mg, Byebedarf,
die allergie unverträgliche Anamnesi wurden verneint.
Vorerkrankungen ergab Zustand nach Ependectomy in alter von 14 Jahren.
Er sei nicht raucher, aber er trinke 2 bis 3 Fläche abends seit Langem.
Er trinkt 2 bis 3 Flaschen,
Er trinkt 2 bis 3 Bier, aber jetzt haben sie nur Flaschen gesagt.
2 Flaschen Schnaps wäre viel, 2 Flaschen Wein wäre auch viel,
2 bis 3 Flaschen Bier ist ja nicht so viel.
Aber er trinkt Bier, ne?
Ja, er trinkt nur Bier, 2 bis 3 Flaschen Bier.
Ja, die Familienanamnesi ergab,
ein Magenschutzkurs, Byebedarf,
und die Kräfte des Kräftes, der Schutzkurs,
wurden mit Operation behandelt.
Er hat gerade gut erholen.
Er holt sich gerade gut, okay?
Ja, seine Mutter und Bruder sind beide gesund.
Er sei Schlosler in einer Maschinefabrik,
und er habe kein Stress.
Er sei verheiratet und wohne mit seinem Frau zusammen.
Er habe 3 gesunde Kinder.
Er ist, er sei vollständig geimpft gegen auch 3 Mal Corona.
Er treibe kein Sport.
Er treibe die Anamnestische Angaben auf,
um die Ähisten, die Podagrahen,
die Differenz der Diagnostik zu kommen,
vielleicht eine Faktur,
die Luxadislokation am Großzüge in Betracht.
Falls Sie meinen Verdacht bestätigen, würde ich gerne die folgenden Massnahmen durchführen.
Was machen Sie denn erst mal diagnostisch?
Ich will sofort eine Röntgenbild und die Hanzeure Han-Urykacit.
Ich nehme das Labo ab.
Sie machen Labo-Untersuchung?
Natürlich, Köpelsuntersuchung.
Worauf können Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Die Inspektion ist wichtig und natürlich die Fußabstasthen.
Die Überwärmung, Rötungen und ja, vielleicht ein Insek-Pistich-Anschau-Traum-Untersuchung.
Also Inspektion, ja.
Beide rechts und links muss ich anschauen.
Ich muss auch Puls-Sensibilitation anschauen.
Also einmal die Pulse und einmal die Sensibilität pulsen.
Welche Pulse füllen Sie denn?
Ja, dorsalis pedis, arteria dorsalis pedis, arteriativialis posterior.
Alles gut.
Okay, ja.
Aber wahrscheinlich zielführend für Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose wäre vor allen Dingen die Blutuntersuchung.
Was wäre denn die Behandlung, wenn der Patient tatsächlich eine Podagra-Anfall hat?
Es ist am wichtigsten sofort eine Schmerz-Therapie.
Und danach aber Urkos-Therapie, Al-Dak-Sprünillakton.
Zuerst muss ich profen oder nicht, für die Antiromatische.
Ich denke diese Potient kann nur ambulanzer Therapie reichen und Kühlung, Hochlagerung.
Das ist ziemlich gut, ja.
Natürlich köpelsche Schonung wichtig.
Und muss man Alkohol, Karrens, Protein, Arme dient und danach die Langzeitige Therapie.
Ja, sehr gut. Okay.
Und was hat der Patient gesagt, als Sie ihm das angekündigt haben,
dass er weniger Alkohol trinken soll und weniger Fleisch essen?
Ja, es ist schwer. Ich denke noch mal, dass es nicht nur Medikamente gibt.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir Kochen-Tablet geben, bei Akute-Therapie.
Und wenn es schwer ist, können wir auch Steroid-Therapie geben.
Ja, okay.
Gut. Ja, sehr schön.
Dann bin ich gespannt, dass bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt, ob es da eine Überraschung gibt
oder ob der sich tatsächlich bei der Verlassdiagnose einfandelt,
dass er wirklich einen Gericht anfalle.
Jetzt muss ich wieder überlegen, wie heißt Gift auf Lateinisch?
Wie ist der Fachbegriff?
Urikasitz.
Ich muss tatsächlich eben gucken.
Urikopoti.
Ich?
Artritis-Urika.
Ja, genau.
Irgendwas mit Urika, das wusste ich, aber wie das...
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, genau, Artritis-Urika.
Gut, sehr gut. Ja, von der Harnsäure.
Gut, ja, ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden und dann geben Sie den Patienten vielleicht ein Merkblatt mit
zur Ernährung in dem Fall, worauf er besonders achten soll.
Gut.
Okay.
Sie haben sich wackergeschlagen, so fachlich, wie da überhaupt kein Thema.
Sie haben sehr gezielt den Patienten befragt,
hatten sehr schön Ihre Liste dabei, haben da systematisch alles abgefragt.
Sie haben gemerkt, dass ich zwischendurch mal so ein bisschen reklamiert habe,
wenn grammatikalische Probleme waren.
Sie haben gemerkt, der Patient war so ein bisschen ungehalten,
was will die denn noch alles wissen?
Und wirklich, ich glaube, wenn ich akut mit meinen Gitschmerzen da zum Klinikum
bin ich nicht geneigt, mir Ermanungen bezüglich meiner Lebensführung anzuhören.
Dann kann ich zwar sagen, oh, oder kann der Arzt zwar sagen, oh,
das ist aber nicht wenig Alkohol oder, hm, das ist aber ein erheblicher Fleischkonsum,
aber man muss das eigentlich zunächst mal kommentalos stehen lassen.
Da kann man in Nachhinein, das ist dann vielleicht Sache des Hausarztes, zu sagen,
Herr Betge, wir müssen mal über Ihren Lebensstil sprechen.
Und da werden wir etwas ändern müssen, kann man auch besser nach der Diagnose machen,
wenn man wirklich sicher ist, das war es.
Sowieso, die Patienten provozieren, wir wollen mal ein bisschen wissen,
ja, was war es denn jetzt, woran liegt es denn, warum tut es mir weh?
Und lassen Sie sich da gar nicht auf eine Diskussion ein.
Lassen Sie sich nicht auf die Diskussion ein, der Patient ist im Zweifel,
Falle Leie, so wie dieser hier, ja, und weiß relativ wenig über Gesundheit
und über seinen Körper, der weiß nur, pustet weh, ja.
Und vielleicht hat er auch schon mal gehört, dass zu viel Fleisch essen
und zu viel Alkohol trinken ungesund ist, aber das macht er ja nun schon seit 10 Jahren
und da will er sich erst mal nicht einreden lassen.
Also würde ich mich da wirklich gar nicht auf eine große Diskussion einlassen.
Es sei denn der Patient fragt, ja, was kann ich denn dagegen tun?
Kann ich irgendwas ändern?
Ja, gut, dann kann man ihm natürlich etwas anbieten, aber so, denk ich mal,
Schmerzen von 7 bis 8 sind krasse Schmerzen, ja, da ist er nicht besonders diskussios bereit.
Ja, sicher.
Und ja, und Sie haben sich da auch, ich habe das natürlich jetzt wieder nicht so schnell auch geschrieben,
Sie haben sich da auch ein bisschen verhellert sprachlich, als Sie gesagt haben,
ja, wir können Ihnen Hilfe anbieten, in unserer Klinik gibt es auch eine Sozialabfernung,
Sie sollten Ihren Alkoholkonsum verringern, schön und gut, das können wir wissen, ja,
dass das so ist, aber ich denke, ist nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt,
ist eher im Nachgespräch dann vielleicht so ein Thema.
Und natürlich ist es richtig gegenüber dem Oberarzt zu sagen,
das sind die Empfehlungen für den Patienten, Alkoholverzicht, Nahrungsumstellung, logisch, ganz klar.
Ja, Augenblick, ja, was mir aufgefallen ist,
das ist aber sicherlich ein kleiner Versprecher gewesen im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
Sie hatten über Vorerkrankungen gesprochen und eine Vorerkrankung, Vorerkrankungen ist bekannt
und dann ist es ja nur eine Vorerkrankung, also er hat nur erhöhte Blutwertwerte
und da könnte man dann vielleicht besser sagen, zur Frage nach Vorerkrankungen
gibt der Patient lediglich an, dass der Arzt bei ihm einmal oder bei ihm schon mehrfach erhöhte Blutwertwerte festgestellt hat,
er nimmt aber aktuell keine Medikamente und er hält auch keine Diäne ein.
Und dann haben sie nachher, glaube ich, einen Versprecher gehabt,
weil sie gesagt haben, an Vorerkrankungen wurde er wegen einer, wurde er abenektomiert,
da meinten sie Voroperationen, die Frage nach Voroperationen,
wurde dahingehend beantwortet, dass er als Kind oder im Alter von 14 Jahren abenektomiert wurde.
Gut, ja, ganz klar, sind die, es sind ihre Verdachtsdiagnosen und Differenzialdiagnosen, das war alles korrekt.
Spontanfraktur wäre vielleicht noch interessant, also Trauma haben sie ja schon gesagt, Traumastraktur,
Spontanfraktur, was man vielleicht noch ein- kalkulieren könnte, wäre noch eine rheumatische Erkrankung,
Arthritis oder rheumatische Arthritis, so ganz typisch ist es natürlich nicht,
weil der so eine klassische, so eine klassische Symptomatik eigentlich schildert und auch so ein Paradepatient ist.
Man sieht den ja förmlich vor sich, so ein bisschen rotes Gesicht,
rotes Gesicht und ordentlich Speck auf den Rippen und ja, das passt eigentlich ja schon alles zu ihrer ersten Diagnose.
Ja, vergessen Sie nie die körperliche Untersuchung, ja, und machen Sie sich dadurch aus, so Punkte,
wo Sie sagen, das muss auf alle Fälle rein, als erstes guckt man, als erstes guckt man,
dann fühlt man und dann macht man die speziellen Untersuchungen.
Und natürlich ist Blutentnahme das A und O, ganz klar, und auch das Reunden des Fußes,
um von vornherein auszuschließen, dass der da eine Fraktur hat, völlig klarer Reihen.
Gut und auch ihre Therapieempfehlungen natürlich, Colethezine und auf Dauersenkung des Hansaurespielen.
Gut, ja, es bleibt dabei, dass eben dramatikal schon noch einiges im Argen ist,
verstehen konnte ich Sie überwiegend, Sie mich glaube ich auch, war also nie so,
dass wir irgendwie völlig aneinander vorbeigeredet haben und ja,
ich überlege gerade an irgendeiner Stelle, war das einmal, war das bei der Sache mit der Empfehlung,
mit der Empfehlung, mit dem Alkohol, ich bin das aufgefallen, dass das auch sprachlich dann ein bisschen durcheinander ging.
Und ich meine noch an irgendeiner Stelle, haben Sie sich so ein klein bisschen verharkt,
aber ja, und ich habe insbesondere im Arztgespräch, habe ich hier auch ein paar Korrekturen dann sprachlich gemacht,
wenn das ganz dolt und aneinander ging.
Immer, es ist immer so eigentlich bei allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen, auch bei Ihnen,
der Ananeseteil ist flüssiger, da sind Sie natürlich der Macher, ja,
und haben den Patienten im Griff sozusagen und nachher müssen Sie bringen, ja,
und das ist immer sprachlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Und Sie hatten ja nun auch sich extrem wenig Vorbereitungszeit genommen,
sondern Sie haben gesagt, ja, okay, mache ich gleich weiter,
sonst hätten Sie vielleicht auch noch das eine oder andere ein bisschen anders formuliert,
wenn Sie mehr Zeit haben in der Prüfung, wird das sicherlich noch ein bisschen eleganter.
Okay?
Okay, danke schön.